pascal à un message par semaine de la
part de sa fille depuis la série en juin
dernier la jeune femme laisse malgré
elle sa mère sans nouvelles pour cause
d'incarcération le silence dure quatre
mois
mais en novembre les premiers signes de
vie que parce qu'elle reçoit de sa fille
ne sont pas bons composteurs sont très
très cher est ce que je veux pas du tout
mais on leur a dit que je risquais ma
vie de temps la fille de pascal rejoint
le groupe etat islamique en 2015
à la suite d'une relation amoureuse elle
les emmène ses trois enfants et en aura
un quatrième sur place sont marine un
français converti il meurt en 2017
aujourd'hui elle vit dans un camp à
rouge dans le nord-est de la syrie
l'opération onéreuse dont elle parle lui
ai proposé parce qu'elle est malade
la jeune femme de 32 ans a développé une
tumeur au niveau du côlon elle maigrit
perdu 100 et ne peut plus s'alimenter
elle demande donc de rentrer en france
afin d'être opéré et jugé pour cela
pascal multiplie les procédures sans
réponse il faut que ça cesse parce que
on tombe dans l'ignoble et dans
l'inhumain même s'il m'a pied doit être
puni etc
on peut pas la laisser mourir à petit
feu comme un animal et si on n'a pas de
pitié qu'on veut pas accorder des droits
humains des droits dans le respect des
droits humains à la fij
j'estime qu'on doit secours et
protection petits enfants je trouve que
c'est triste
à notre époque où sein de la république
d'être obligé de parler aux autorités
par le biais de médias alors que eux ne
demandent pas mieux me rencontrer
quelqu'un d'expliquer mais face à
l'inaction pascal a entamé le 1er
février une grève de la faim
c'est une solution de
la dernière extrémité pour cette grand
mère et cette maman tous les recours
judiciaires gracieux les lettres
adressées à plusieurs membres du
gouvernement
au cabinet du premier ministre à la
présidence de la république non données
strictement aucun résultat cette jeune
maman est frappé d'une amende à d'arrêt
international il doit être judiciariser
elle n'attend qu'une chose c'est de
pouvoir répondre aux questions des juges
d'instruction si c'est fait pourquoi
mandat d'arrêt international
c'est pour interpeller une personne dont
on ne sait pas où elle se trouve et qui
est en fuite
dans le cas présent c'est pas le cas
elle n'est pas en fuite il est en prison
et on sait où elle se trouve et les
autorités françaises rentrer dans ce
camp comme elles l'entendent
la semaine dernière le centre national
d'accompagnement familial face à
l'emprise sectaire a lancé un appel à la
première dame
brigitte macron